I'm so excited to be sitting here with
kid ink for the hottest MCs working
today
yeah thanks so much for being I
appreciate you me that you Jesus piece
this is my Jesus piece on my hand this
is the one and only never-before-seen is
there's a the debut of that Jesus this
isn't the debut but this is the only one
I've ever seen
I got it custom-made it looks dangerous
though it is when I shake hands
sometimes I cut people it's like yeah
yeah see that crown of thorns it'll get
you every time and every time
have you ever punched someone with the
Lord no I will punch you with the Lord
that sounds that would sound dangerous
well it hurts you then it kills you
right away is that how you grew up yes
when the church my mother had me in
church early is that what you got in
first interested in music cuz the music
you know what I wasn't acquired I was in
a gospel choir - yeah for real and that
was the first time that I was onstage
was like like doing little sermons for
my Bibles it's still just a scary man
even though people are opposed to judge
you in churches right what is a stamp or
my stupid is that Atlanta no alumni hey
you desire we had someone designed it it
was the company was put together by me
and it will you know shared ideas and
went through a bunch of different logos
from a designer and landed on - that was
really wouldn't you know I'm successful
that's really cool I also want to replay
the tape where I nodded like I knew who
it will was yeah the company was put
together by me and it will yeah it was
my managing partner looks like I get
what are people you Jordan fives Jordan
five fours fives fives
I have those you yeah they hurt my arcs
yeah no arch support certain Jordans
feel good certain you can't wear for too
long I just I'm more of this guy yeah
because they're comfortable with this
that's none of a hip-hopper air I know
yeah I figured I had a really big moment
and you had a polo moment I know I used
to be like rap emceeing like graffiti
right and break yeah
but nowadays it has a lot to do with
your emcee ability but it also has to do
with like your grant like what you wear
with like how you come across
yeah a lot of pressure it's funny
because it will says like a it's a
wrestler mentality you know when they
say you know like Hogan was the first
wrestler to brand himself and it was all
about more than Jesse knows selling
things you know I'm saying coming up
with the not a costume but a look what
is your favorite rhyme of your something
that was really creative or weird like
that you had to bend the word or
shouldn't've rhyme but you pulled it off
with you waiver my favorite one
that's a yeah with the flavor that's a
good one
I've been called out for sometimes
thinking i oh i slurred a word good
enough and this is my like yes see what
you tried to do